if someone had said to you in December
that by April millions of people all
over the world would be infected with a
mysterious new virus that has no vaccine
you'd think they were talking about a
Hollywood script it's happened so fast
it almost doesn't seem real and it has
everyone asking when will it end
Jackson prosecco went looking for
answers this is not normal at least it
wasn't until a few weeks ago when
everything we take for granted
everything moved just beyond our grasp
six weeks ago nobody worried about
touching their own face or leaving their
own house nobody thought about lining up
to buy groceries now there are more
planes on the ground than in the sky
work has become a luxury for those who
still have a job especially for those
who can work from home and home is where
most of us now spend our time sitting
and wondering how we get back to the
world we knew we know that the mass
social distancing measures will will
work they will bring cases down we've
seen that everywhere they've been tried
and it stands to reason that if everyone
stops going outside their house that
case transmission will slow considerably
the problem is you can't sustain that
indefinitely Jeremy Coonan Dyke is an
expert in pandemic preparedness at the
Center for global development in
Washington DC he like virtually every
expert has bad news for anyone who
thinks there's an easy road back you
need a plan B phase two you have to pass
the baton to a different set of
protective measures so that you can keep
cases low while actually having a
functional economy again and allowing
people to move again you governments
have such a plan they're still dealing
with an unfolding health disaster and a
mysterious new virus COBIT 19 is
stealthy and it's lethal no one appears
to have natural immunity no one knows
how widespread infections really are or
if the virus will come and go with the
seasons the 1918 flu pandemic went on
till 1920 so this could easily go on a
couple of years waxing and waning and
dr. Peter
has is a vaccine scientist at Baylor
College of Medicine in Houston he
believes governments need a strategy for
how daily life will operate for the next
two years yes two years that's the
length of time it could take to develop
tests and distribute a vaccine once the
surge in cases is over do you see us
potentially getting to a place where
restrictions and social distancing are
loosened and then tightened up as
localized outbreaks pop up yeah that's
that's a possible scenario but how do
you operationalize that and and and how
do you inform companies or universities
when to stay open when to close and how
do you get people to feel comfortable
doing that who might be terrified about
resuming normal daily activity so a lot
of complexities without a lot of
precedent the complexity is not lost on
public officials anywhere they've
struggled to explain what a way out
might look like if back to normal means
acting like there never was a
coronavirus problem I don't think that's
gonna happen until we do have a
situation where you can completely
protect the population I think even
after we're through this first wave we
will need to remain vigilant and we will
need to bring in different measures
normality as it was before will not come
back full-on until we get a vaccine for
this
in South Korea they've learned that
social distancing is only half the
battle the government implemented an
aggressive system of testing contact
tracing public alerts and quarantine to
keep case numbers and fatalities
relatively low even then life is nowhere
close to returning to what it once was
the virus keeps popping up other
countries have begun to relax
restrictions only to experience a second
wave of infection Canada the US and
Europe are still at step 1 trying to
contain the outbreak and public health
officials say they're nowhere close to
being ready to think about anything else
how are we going to get back to normal
without higher levels of testing like if
people are walking around with this
virus that they don't even know it right
now our focus is to tackle this actual
outbreak at some point in the near
future we'll be looking at how do we
apply serologic testing for example to
look at the level of immunity in the
population even though everything shut
down all at once it may come back slowly
in waves once the peak of cases is over
perhaps restaurants and bars reopen with
fewer seats inside schools could come
next big concerts and sporting events
are likely a long way off dr. ali mock
dodd worked to develop the pandemic
models used by the white house so until
we have a vaccine our definition of
normal should be totally different what
normal is so I don't expect all of us to
be back to normal as 100% immediately
but in a staged approach to make sure
the virus is not circulating and we
don't allow this virus to have a second
wave the risk is in coming back too fast
there's little room for trial and error
when human lives are on the line dr.
Lena when is the former public health
commissioner for the city of Baltimore I
don't think that you can lift it over
all all together and say let's go back
to exactly what our Priya komen 19 days
were like that's not going to work
because we know what the consequence is
going to be we're going to have a huge
number of deaths and koba 19 will spiral
out of control
almost every expert agrees a vaccine is
the fastest safest way to get our world
back even if it means a year or more of
waiting until that happens we're stuck
in a cat and mouse game with something
that can't be seen or detected until
it's too late it may be the most painful
weight of our lives so we're in this for
a while we are and it is a new normal
that we all have to get used to
recognizing how difficult this is and
how many sacrifices are going to be
borne by everyone but if we stop down
then these sacrifices will be in vain
and it will take much longer and many
more lives will be lost